let's say we want to figure out what
eight divided by four tenths is pause
this video and try to figure it out on
your own before we do it together all
right now one way to approach this is to
think about everything in terms of
tenths and why tenths you ask well I
just described the second number as four
tenths so what would it be in terms of
tenths
well we know that we know that one whole
is equal to ten tenths so eight holes is
going to be equal to 80 tenths so I
could write that down over here instead
of eight I can write that as 80 tenths
and I'm taking 80 tenths and I'm
dividing that by divided by four tenths
I'm just writing it out four tenths so
if I have 80 of something and if I'm
dividing it into groups of four of that
something how many equal groups am I
going to have well I'm gonna have 80
divided by four groups or 80 divided by
four eight divided by four actually let
me just write it down this is going to
be equal to 80 over four or 80 divided
by 4 and 8 divided by 4 is 2 so 80
divided by 4 is going to be equal to 20
so 8 divided by 4 tenths is equal to 20
another way that you could think about
that is to rewrite 8 divided by 4 tenths
as 8 over 4 tenths over 4 tenths and
then if you wanted to rewrite this you
could say hey can I multiply the
numerator and the denominator by some
quantity that'll get rid of the decimal
in the denominator well I could multiply
the denominator by 10 and if I don't
want to change the value of the fraction
I have to multiply the numerator by that
same amount well that what does that get
us
well this is going to be equal to in the
denominator right over here I'm just
going to have a 4 so we got rid of the
decimal and the numerator I am going to
get 80 so once again we get 80 over 4
which is equal to 20 let's do another
example but in this case we'll deal with
hundredths so let's say we want to
figure out what is 48 divided by
0.24 or 24 hundredths pause this video
and try to figure that out alright well
we can do something very similar
this time we're dealing with hundreds so
we could try to express everything in
terms of hundredths so 48 is equal to
how many hundredths well we know that 1
is equal to 100 hundredths undress so 48
so 48 is going to be equal to 48 times
100 hundreds and maybe I'll just write
it like that or you might be able to say
hey that's 48 hundred or 4,800
hundredths so let's just actually I'll
write it that way this is going to be
4,800 hundreds hundreds divided by this
is 24 hundredths 24 hundredths and so
what's that going to be well same logic
as we used up here if I have 4,800 of
something or 4,800 of something and if
I'm dividing it into equal groups of 24
of that something well I'm going to have
four thousand eight hundred divided by
24 equal groups
so this is going to be equal to 4,800
over 24 we could express 4,800 as of
course 48 times 100 so this is equal to
48 times 100 over 24 and of course you
could view this as the same thing as
this is equal to 48 over 24 48 over 24
and many of you might have already done
it in your head
times 100 what's 48 divided by 24 well
that is going to be equal to 2 so 2
times 100 is equal to 200 so this right
over here is equal to 200 you could also
do it in this type or do it the similar
the way we did this where instead of
expressing it out as words you could
express it as 48 over 24 hundredths and
instead of multiplying the numerator
by 10:00 maybe you want to multiply it
by something else to get whole numbers
in both the numerator denominator think
about that after this video and try to
work it out that way as well